24 septembre 1999 le centre de sangatte
accueille ses tout premiers réfugiés
dans ce hangar la croix-rouge recueil
300 pensionnaires des kosovars en
majorité pour une durée très provisoire
on est parti je pense pour l'hiver après
ça sera une question de moyens mais on
fera autant que nécessaire tant qu'il y
aura des gens qui ont besoin d'être
d'être mis à l'abri nourish sangatte à
dix kilomètres de calais 900 habitants à
l'époque le village devient une étape
clé sur la route des migrants vers la
grande bretagne
en quelques mois la cohabitation se
complique
une pétition pour la fermeture est
remise à la préfecture
signé par une majorité de sangatte wwa
est ce que vous réclamez qu'ils s'en
aillent en faveur aussi de la fermeture
la société eurotunnel
le centre est devenu une salle
d'attentes de l'immigration avant la
traversée vers la grande-bretagne à
proximité de l'entrée du tunnel sous la
manche
l'organisation du passage créé des
perturbations considérables à
l'exploitation pour nos clients qui
subissent des retards considérables la
nuit c'est le moment où passent tous les
camions tous les trains de marchandises
de l'europe entière
c'est donc des conditions qui sont
inacceptables le tribunal a choisi de ne
pas fermer le centre mais la commune
devient le point de crispation de
l'immigration clandestine des réseaux
mafieux s'organise vers ce lieu de
transit en juillet 2002 le ministre de
l'intérieur se saisit de la sphère
nicolas sarkozy annonce la fermeture du
centre
on peut aujourd'hui envisager une
fermeture de sangatte qui serait
comprise entre le dernier trimestre 2002
et le premier trimestre 2003 'l'annonce
fait frémir une partie des réfugiés à
sangatte les kurdes et les afghans
surtout des gens je vais me faire tuer
le démantèlement de sangatte est prévue
pour décembre 2002 pour les 1600
réfugiés un accord a été trouvé avec la
grande bretagne
elle accueillera 70 % des résidents du
centre la france régularisera la
situation des 30% restants bonne
nouvelle pour les migrants et pour
l'équipe du centre déborde d face à
l'afflux à sangatte
vers la fin nous avions jusqu'à 100
personnes par par jour qui arrive et ce
qui était énorme et je crois qu'il
fallait bien marquer au près
réseaux de passeurs mafieux que c'était
terminé compris qu'il ne pouvait plus
compter sur un réservoir comme l'était
sangatte le 23 décembre 2002 trois ans
après son ouverture le centre de
sangatte est démolie environ 68 mille
migrants sont passés entre ses murs la
dernière étape vers la grande bretagne
s'est alors déplacée à calais les
prémices de la dite jungle démantelé à
son tour en 2007
[Musique]